thank you our security what do we do
about security and how can we improve
security first of all we've got to stop
taking people take their shoes I'll take
their belt off and allow people we
carrying the girls all of the things
we're doing for screening people and
screening cargo cannot possibly work
with the sheer volume of people we had
to be a volume as goods we had working
around the world means that all this
physical meets of security cannot
possibly work and we have to concentrate
on risk assessment and thread essential
they have to get all the information
that businesses give to customs to get
out to the people who know where the bad
guys are that is the CIA security forces
the FBI is here on time Special Branch
all those people know who the bad guys
are we have to have computers talking to
computers which is difficult and a bit
expensive but it's better than
inconvenient inconveniencing people and
stopping the trailer of goods which
can't work anyway speed was impressive
ok thank you sir